these behind me are all the negative
comments from last week's video people
telling me that I'm better and that it
was a letdown yes I went into some weird
adventurous realm of creativity but it
was an itch I needed to scratch okay I
just want to thank those with the guts
for giving me actual criticism as much
as I want to climb to the top of my
self-righteous creative pedestal and
scream I actually don't
uploading films on YouTube is a really
humbling experience I do most of the
feedback even the good I picked up that
you're looking for something something
real so that's exactly what I did this
week anything for you
[Music]
[Applause]
8 a.m. in the morning in my apartment in
New York City this is what it sounds
this is my office
if I can't escape the noise well I might
as well embrace it
60% of the human body is made out of
water in the chaos it's disrupted but
through rhythm it creates patterns ah
music is rooted in our human DNA
dependent on flow created by a simple
uninterrupted cadence imagine you could
zoom in through the chaos of everyday
life and find the rhythm I'm going to
perform an experiment by walking down
Broadway in Manhattan the whole way to
the southern tip with my camera to
record different sounds over the
duration of the day then call up mermaid
Nagy who will help me make music out of
the sounds of the streets this is that
me
it's 3:45 in the morning I'm on the
northern tip okay I'm gonna try that
again
it's 344 well now it's about 4 a.m. in
the morning let the sounds begin
in New York
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the Sun is just started rising in the
cities becoming very chaotic this is
Broadway it takes a split yeah what I've
realized today is that sounds are
defined by the objects they are attached
to so if you just close your eyes like
New York is so rich with sounds but
there's so many different objects you
can attach the sounds to which makes
this project really interesting and
really fun and dynamic just going around
trying to search for the richest most
raw sound and I can really feel the
soundtrack and just like feel whoa
this is so rad I'm so stiff it's one of
that and you can just so I can have like
I can show you this shot of my granny
with the horse egg
[Music]
[Music]
I just found a guy named Jana in the
street for that stuff this [ __ ] time
I finally made it to the end of Broadway
after today I've realized that micro
travel is an exceptional idea that I'd
like to share with you I think all the
wrong self-indulgent films about travel
is what cloud our judgement about this
term to seek the [ __ ] that only exists
in most of our dreams appreciate the
small adventures like why not cruise
through your hood and start looking for
things through a new lens maybe just
close your eyes and listen or feel these
are the stories that should be shared on
this platform ones that are attainable
for all thank you once again to all for
coming on this mission with me and a
special thanks to notch which I'm
putting on board with me to create the
soundtrack thank you to all the other
filmmakers that helped me I'll link them
all in the description below you can
download the track here that nagy made
he's also released all the samples so
you can take them and create your own
soundtrack if you like go give them a
follow and then as always if you like my
movies and want me to make more please
subscribe to my channel next week's
video will be about love last
and a formula about how to live a dub
and happy life see you next Wednesday
done let's get out
[Music]
you
[Music]